hello I'm a mushroom how how's it
going uh do you come to this tree root
often
H nice to see you pick up lines in the
[Laughter]
[Music]
melium this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
today we're doing Cosmic
queries on none other than silos cbin oh
my gosh Chuck Nice we haven't done one
of these before no uh the Salos cybin or
the uh or the
queries queries on Salos cbin I don't
think I've done either to be honest yeah
that's the voice of Chuck Nice Chuck
always good to have you man always a
pleasure well I certainly have no
expertise in this subject and I don't
know if Chuck you do I intend to you
intend to okay
so but we at since we find the academics
wherever they roam where the expertise
can be found we've got it in Brinn
dentinger Brinn welcome to Star talk
thank you very much Neil and Chuck it's
a real pleasure to be here so you're a
curator of
micology not eurology
mology that's right at the Natural
History Museum in Utah and your
principal investigator in the dentinger
lab what a coincidence
there what are the
odds and you're co-author of a just
published study at the publications of
the National Academy of Sciences on the
phylogenomics of silic cybin
mushrooms whoa so this is so first tell
me what a myologist is ey out of his
mind what no go ahead but a myologist is
somebody that studies fungi fungi is a
whole Kingdom of Life relative to plants
and animals there's the whole fungus
Kingdom and we know so much less about
them than we do plants and animals so
mushrooms are just a part of all fungi
um many fun molds and yeasts things that
you might be more familiar with on your
bread or your shower you know when I
wasn't looking fungus became an entire
branch of the Tree of Life an entire
Kingdom and that was based on their mode
of nutrition so how they get their food
basically so animals ingest things and
fungi absorb things and so that was
emphasized uh when they removed them
from from Plants I see okay and another
thing I learned just recently like what
five years ago that the common ancestor
between mushrooms fungus and animals
parted later than its common ancestor
parted with green plants which logically
tells us that we and mushrooms are more
genetically alike than either we or
mushrooms are to green plants I I think
I can say that isn't that correct that
is absolutely true yeah so we share a
common ancestor with fungi about a
billion and a half years ago so that's
quite a long time things have changed
quite a bit obviously we don't do I'm an
astrophysicist you right okay yeah so
that's like that's like a I was gonna
say Split Second right right drop in the
proverbial bucket we got this okay go
on yeah so we've we look entirely
different today you know the one track
the animals they went through this
internal uh absorption or sorry
digestion and then the fungi they
they're sort of the opposite they're
like our stomachs turned inside out so
they just live inside their food squirt
their enzymes out to their environment
they break stuff down and they reabsorb
them and that's why it look so different
yeah
okay so so what what is a
syosin yeah so this is a small molecule
that some mushrooms produce big
molecule that's saw a molecule ambling
down the street the other day no I know
you can get very big biological
molecules yeah yeah but I mean that's
fair they're all small you can't see it
um and about 200 species of mushrooms
around the world produce this compound
and nobody knows why they make it but
one thing that we do know is the way
they make it is very highly regulated
using a combination of like four genes
that encode enzymes that convert the
amino acid tryptophan to psybin just
four in just four steps so why they do
this is a matter of huge
speculation um and of course you may you
and your doers may already know that one
of the uh activities of cybin when it's
consumed is to produce um Altered States
Of Consciousness in humans and and other
animals mammals primarily or all animals
no matter what hasn't been tested very
widely so we can't really say but
certainly all the mammals that's been
tested on show behaviors that are
consistent with an altered state of
consciousness okay so there's some
mushrooms that are just simply tasty
others take you on mental trips and
others will kill you so oh let's hope
they never all get
together we are in big trouble
the
[Laughter]
world yeah so this range of things it
can do to us um is it just random it
happens to be that way I mean there's a
lot of species of fungus for sure it's
not entirely random at least not in all
cases um in the case of syosin it might
be what we call a happy accident that it
affects us that way it might be that
that chemical has some other function in
nature that we don't yet
understand it chases back 65 million
years that's that's awfully suspicious
time frame in the history yeah of life
on Earth are we are we to believe that
the dinosaurs were high that's why they
didn't realize that they about to get
wiped out like hey man look at that
thing in the sky oh man that is really
really cool man that's rad man look at
that oh my God look at the trail on it
man the colors the
colors yeah I mean I mean that's little
suspicious what can you say about that I
mean I I couldn't prove Chuck's
hypothesis wrong
but Chuck is good at those kinds of
hypotheses by the way but I'll say two
things one is our ability to precisely
pinpoint the origin of this in absolute
time is pretty poor so you know there's
a huge range of of of possible dates
that this originated we call this a
confidence interval and so you know the
65 million just happen to be sort of in
the middle of that range it was the mean
but it doesn't mean that that was
precisely the time at which this
molecule appeared that said um an
interesting consequence of the asteroid
hitting Earth is that it created a
nuclear winter which blocked out
sunlight and sunlight is necessary for
plants to grow so there were no plants
around and therefore there was nothing
that could eat plants right they were
going to go extinct things that needed
to eat plants they're they're going to
go extinct as well but things that don't
rely on live plants to feed and survive
could Thrive under those conditions and
that happens to be mushrooms that
decompose dead organic material and
things like slugs and snails that eat
decomposing material so those kinds of
organisms they actually did well after
the as impact you know I had put two and
two together there to make that draw
that conclusion makes perfect sense so
so there's is the great dying of organic
matter
and and this is a happy day for
mushrooms and
snails it does appear that mushrooms
Diversified re very rapidly after the
asteroid impact in many groups so yeah
it may have been an opportunity for them
Silver Lining yeah The World Is Ours
just a couple more questions before we
go to the to our Q&A Chuck you loaded up
with the patreon questions I do I have
them okay so how did we discover this
chemical in them is just is it people
grazing mushrooms until I mean they
can't have been motivated to expect this
so I guess was it just random and do we
have a can we date that in the history
of
culture what we don't know about
prehistory and what kind of interactions
our ancestors had with these mushrooms
because it's not recorded but we do know
that uh miso Americans history just
astronomically history goes back to the
Big Bang so you mean history in the
historian sense where we actually have
records of people places events and
things our history yeah correct correct
we also don't have a history of its use
at the time of the Big Bang just to to
be clear yeah who knows maybe maybe it
is the reason for the Big Bang somebody
somebody
it but in all seriousness um the first
people that were documented to use it
were mesoamericans and this was
discovered when Europeans first arrived
in mesom America and and wrote it down
and then proceeded to ban its use of
course because it was total sacrilege
right exactly so that the knowledge was
suppressed for hundreds of years until
it was sort of rediscovered by an
American ex-
Banker Gordon Wasson who traveled down
to Mexico on these rumors that they were
still being used for ritual ritualistic
ceremonies and he documented it and
published an article Life magazine in
1957 and that is the source of modern
understanding of the use of magic
mushrooms that's when he coins the term
in fact magic mushrooms
1957 Life Magazine would have thought
and so so I presume there uses for this
chemical besides just taking a a head
trip yeah so unfortunately we haven't
been able to explore that efficiently
for the last 50 years thanks to
suppression of research by Richard Nixon
after he passed the Controlled
Substances Act 19 71 I don't want these
people getting high well it was a it was
a form of social control so he was
concerned about the subculture
subverting his his political dominance
so he created all these um challenges
for people to explore freely in their in
their world but we don't need to get
into politics um what's the hippie I
think the hippies were yeah considered
counter cultural to what the political
agendas were right exctly so and if and
if they're using psilocybin and they're
not otherwise harming other people and
you make that illegal then you can
arrest hippies and get them out of your
way exactly yeah well that's uh
basically the story behind marijuana too
right right yeah yeah but but today
we're now having a a Resurgence of
interest in its medical applications and
it's showing to have profound
therapeutic value for a wide range of
mental illnesses from depression to
PTSD endend of life you know it's sad we
might have known this decades ago and
it's only coming out now very
unfortunate and what are some of the
benefits when you talk about depression
PTSD which are you know um slightly
related um but then you say end of life
is that the um acceptance of end of life
is that a pain management is what what
exactly is it for end of life yeah so I
mean I should I should say that I'm not
a medical doctor so um I I can just tell
you what I've read which is it is really
about you just sell to the
doctors you show up on the
doorstep open your trench coat right
okay not not quite not yet not yet okay
um and it is really about um accepting
your death and coming to terms with
that cool so it doesn't provide any pain
relief right but well Association well I
was going to say that's a that's a
psychological pain reliever yeah yeah
yeah in a
way so Chuck you got question we I think
we've laid some good groundwork here
yeah to see what where these questions
come in absolutely let's uh jump right
into it um this is
Patrick uh weglinski Patrick weglinski
from um Salt Lake City Utah and he says
oh another Utah person another Utah
person Utah Utah I'm worried now you're
all gathering together or something
planning something well this is the
place that's what Brigham Young said
when he right this is the place he says
hello Dr dettinger uh I've been trying
to get into micology and it can be very
difficult I find it much harder than
growing plants why are mushrooms so
difficult to grow on purpose or by
accident uh why do mushrooms need to
have a super sterile condition in order
to grow in an artificial environment but
can grow in the nastiest conditions in
the world wild that's right that's so
true in fact I saw a crack in the
pavement and the mushroom was popping up
through the crack in the absolutely so
what's up with that yes yeah so it turns
out that unlike plants they have to
compete for resources that already exist
and there's a lot of things competing
for the same resources and so it's just
through competition that it you get a
lot of contamination things that better
faster green plants do compete for
sunlight yes right but they but there's
an abundance of
sunlight right whereas you're describing
resources in the environment that if one
person gets it the other doesn't right
and when you're growing a plant you're
not going to grow it in the shade of
another plant right you're gonna you're
gonna manipulate its environment to make
it Thrive but to do that with a fungus
the only way you can manipulate the
environment is to make sure there's no
other organisms present that can
outcompete it so you have to sterilize
it but why they occur in nature well
this is just a numbers game so every
every mushroom just for example will
produce maybe up to a trillion
spores those trillion spores have to
find a mate they're not a full seed so
they haven't made it yet but there's
half a trillion possible individuals
reproductively mature
individuals mushrooms that are out there
exactly yeah that's a much more concise
way of putting it look at that a
statistical bias yeah that's right right
okay so if if so if your guy chuck had a
trillion
pots right he'll get mushrooms in some
of them he'll get some mushrooms with no
problem right or he could just keep a
very dirty
shower all right well that's cool that's
a that's a that's a great thing that's a
cool answer too uh this is Stone Courier
and stone says hello Dr Tyson Dr deter
and Lord nice this is Stone from Boston
Massachusetts and yes Chuck that's my
real name hey man you know I was gonna
say it sounded very very Hollywood but
okay yeah exactly Stone Courier Stone
leading man
exactly sounds like an anchor you know I
know I know right to today's top story
I'm Stone carrier
um he says I've heard that the largest
living organism is one big circuitry of
mushrooms this is incredible and makes
me wonder is this one organism or just a
way for multiple mushrooms to talk also
since they're talking where do mushrooms
lie on the Consciousness scale more than
my tree but less than my dog and finally
is there any evolutionary benefit that
some mushroom rooms give psychedelic
hallucinations when eaten so Bren this
question better be true about mushrooms
being the largest organism because I
wrote about that in my a book I put out
a couple years ago so I'm listening well
yeah it is true Neil it is true so as
far as we know the largest by area the
largest individual organism by area is a
fungus that grows in the Blue Mountains
of Eastern Oregon and it covers an area
of about three and a half square miles
now it may not be the largest in biomass
that may be topped by a cloned Aspen
called Pando in Utah uh but it's
certainly many times larger than a blue
whale and that's kind of surprising to a
lot of people yeah but what makes it one
organism it's not just interconnected
multiple organisms that happen to have
uh that manage to figure out how to have
a network one another yeah
Network yeah so it it appears based on
genetic evidence that it is a single
individ ual that's connected throughout
this 3 and half square miles of forest
through a network ofy which we call the
melium that's the mass of hyy that makes
up an individual and the mushrooms get
produced on the edges of this mycelium
whenever conditions are right or it need
or there's some stimulus that that
causes it to B the mushrooms but they're
simply the reproductive structures so
the the metabolically active organism
the what some people call the vegetative
organism this is just the celium in the
soil right which by the way is an
excellent story propagator in the HBO
series The Last of Us which is so cool
because it's they're mushroom zombies
right right right and they all talk to
one another through a myal network so
they uh and of course in James Cameron's
Avatar he was highly inspired by the
connectivity of multiple organist
right elements yeah so everybody had
like a USB ponytail to connect into the
into the plant that went into the
animals yeah because the whole planet is
connected by one network yeah yeah which
wow that' be so great what about the
hallucinogenics and evolution is there
any link between the two of them um when
it comes to eating mushrooms we don't
know what link there is between
evolution and these hallucinogenic
chemicals but if we take a lesson from
Plants those chemicals are there to
protect the plants from being eaten and
we think that that's probably the case
with the mushrooms as well oh so it's
more of a defense it's a
defense until we came along and then it
became a very poor
defense I'm skeptical forn will prevent
me from reaching into a flower bush Okay
uh
there are things that'll prevent me you
know a bee thing prevents me from
getting closer to the bees a chemical
that takes time to have an effect on my
brain it's too late I already ate the
mushroom so how is it how can that be
thought of as a defense yeah that's an
excellent point Neil and we think that
it's not the chemical that's responsible
for the defense but a conversion of that
chemical into something that would cause
your stomach to burn oh there okay
defense and I associate that bad feeling
with having eaten the
mushroom that would be and that would be
immediate yeah oh go that would be
immediate okay we can totally and and
when people when human beings take um
psilocybin do they experience this kind
of burn or is that part of the
experience feel the burn feel the
burn no because it it it it functions at
a much smaller scale than humans so
these chemicals didn't evolve in
response to humans we know that because
they predate hums by 65 in A9 million
years right at least there you go so uh
we know that so they evolved in response
to something else and probably it's
invertebrates those are the those are
the kinds of animals that cause a lot of
damage to mushrooms particularly land
mollis slugs and snails so that's why we
think that that chemical evolved is a
defense against slugs and snails okay
let's go to Buck rice from Hoboken New
Jersey and but you from Hoboken that's
cheating no not really uh you're not
from Hoboken but you live in Hoboken yes
exactly right um thanks for doxing me on
the
show okay so you live on the east coast
sorry what
I so he
says uh what is the difference between
um solos sabbin and
aasa and if you a friend who owns a
resort in Costa Rica who offered you the
ability to come down and do
iasa uh is that a safe thing to do so I
noticed you weren't reading anything
there chuck oh I'm
so I mean oh my goodness I forgot I said
actually here we go um second half of
that question came Chuck's
ass trying to ride the coel of people
who are paying patreon
members yeah but yeah anyway now now
that it's out
there uh I can't I can't speak to the
safety of iasa um other than it's been
used for probably thousands of years by
indigenous peoples in the Amazon basin
um but it is different the chemistry is
different so one thing about iasa is in
order for it to be active you have to
mix two chemicals together one chemical
inhib the enzyme in your stomach that
would normally deactivate the other
chemical so this is called a monoamine
oxidase inhibitor and monoamine oxidases
are enzymes that are there to protect us
from getting poisoned when we eat things
primarily plants so you're you're
causing that enzyme to no longer
function which if there are other
chemicals involved other than the one in
iasa that makes you high uh that could
be really dangerous so sometimes people
who have anti-depressants um you if you
take an MAO inhibitor with that
anti-depressant that can cause real real
problems so I would I would recommend
you seek some um some medical advice
from a trusted a trusted practitioner
before also from from mushrooms no IAS
is from plants so it's usually two
plants but often there's a mixture of
other plants but the two plants that are
really important are a source of DMT
dimethyl tryptamine which is very
closely related in structure to syosin
but pharmacologically has a slightly
different action and the other compound
um comes is just this m inhibitor which
can come in a variety of of flavors okay
all right so it's it's it's really you
have to deactivate a part a system in
your body to allow the active ingredient
to go to work otherwise it just won't
work that's right wow DM DMT is
widespread in nature particularly plants
it's in many many different plants and
uh this is how we protect ourselves from
getting high all the time when we eat
lettuce oh my God that was the best
salad ever H dude are you kidding me I
got some rain for 20
bucks so if you if you Mainline lettuce
then it doesn't go through your
digestive system right and you know for
the record I don't know if lettuce
produces DMT but sounded good yeah but
do people do administer DMT
intravenously or more commonly they um
vaporize it and inhale it and that
bypasses the digestive
system okay okay gotcha all right um you
know I I've read uh and heard from
others that
iasa does cause severe GI distress right
yeah there's you know I I noticed that
in the pictures where there was a vomit
bucket next to every single bed yeah
yeah so yeah maybe that is something
that is very common gotcha all right
well I'm okay well I'm sure Buck rice is
happy with that
answer keep it coming all right here we
go this is Angus McNeil and Angus says
hello Neil Bren and Chuck I was
wondering that mushrooms have some
medicinal purposes and you can eat most
of them would it make more sense to
start farming mushrooms instead of
traditional crops like wheat thanks
Angus and I'm 13 oh wow yeah good so
yeah is there an environmental
difference between harvesting mushrooms
and harvesting green plants and I'm not
talking about the mushrooms you dig up
and they charge $400 an ounce yeah yeah
yeah and right that that they have to
enslave
pigs dog on Pig labor force
unfortunately so yeah we're not talking
about truffles yeah but if if if
mushrooms are nutritious and of course
they taste meaty which is something no
one ever accused kale of
tasting
what I would I would eat mushroom a bowl
of mushrooms over a bowl of lettuce any
day of the week me too it's true yeah I
got to admit yeah and and nobody has a
kale Burger but people have definitely
had a portabello Burger sure yeah that'd
be a sad Universe right there if that's
all
thing I'd say don't knock it till you
try
it um so cultivating mushroom I I would
say you can't it would be a replacement
for traditional crop plants and that's
because the form of nutrition they
provide is not complete they're not very
um full of carbohydrates for example
which well like like corn right corn or
wheat yeah yeah wheat the grain all the
grains yeah right potatoes grains rice
and potatoes okay right yeah um so I
suppose you know you could go on
a sorry kale no carbohydrates in kale
definitely what is in kale
marketing that's what's in kale a bunch
of
marketing and maybe some DMT yeah oh all
right um so you know they are they're a
good source of proteins and one
important thing is that they have a
complete um they're complete with their
amino acids so unlike vegetables which
are missing amino acids that animals
need fungi have all of the same amino
acids and that of course refers back to
our shared ancestry from a billion and a
half years ago that's why they have the
same amino acids we do so that's
important um and they have some other
vitamins but you wouldn't be able to
survive on mushrooms a lot of the cell
walls that they have are indigestible
like cell walls of plants so they're not
they you can subsist on mushrooms yeah
you're passing them you're not they're
not you're not extracting anything from
them you know but then they that's but
but the protein is a good thing so prot
a I mean so for for
vegetarians mushrooms should be a a
really great addition to their diet for
that reason absolutely yeah but you have
to eat a lot of them because they're 90%
water and that's one of the other
challenges with using mushrooms in place
of meat or other Foods gotcha okay oh
that's a great question there for for
13-year-old Angus mcneel way to
go this is Troy uh um who said that
that's all he says he's
Troy he's like
share or Madonna or Madonna you gotta
know who Troy if you don't know who Troy
is you're missing out okay cause I'm
Troy okay so there you go he says uh Hey
everybody Dr Tyson Chuck brenn Troy from
Virginia here uh do you think life do
you think plant life have any
similarities that relate to the
Frameworks of the
Universe I often feel like trees
mushrooms and plant life have specific
traits that model an attribute of the
universe what do you think that might be
for mushrooms or for fungi so is there
any parallels that you can draw between
the universe and fungi I think this
might be a question for Neil
I officially don't understand the
question well I think what he's saying
is when you look at the human brain and
there are trillions of connections and
then you look at the universe and
there's trillions of stars and you know
that there seems to be there really is
no correlation but there seems to be
some kind of correlation you know is
there any correlation between plant life
and fungi and the universe itself in
either its structure its
composition uh or anything that you
might be able to draw I'm going to say
no okay for the following reason so what
we
learned when we looked out in the beyond
Earth we found planets orbiting the sun
eventually when we put the sun back in
the middle of the known universe so that
was kind of cool okay and then we looked
into the atom and we found electrons
orbiting a nucleus we say that's just
like the planets orbiting the Sun it's
just like it we said to ourselves we
thought to ourselves so but the more we
looked at it the less it resembled it we
even called the paths of the electrons
orbitals named after the planets
orbiting the Sun orbitals and orbital is
is a region of space where you would
find the electron point is that
different laws of physics apply for
smaller Gatherings of matter than for
larger Gatherings different laws of
physics so you can't sort of linear go
from one scale to another and then
expect to have any clue what's happening
in that other scale all right how about
Andrew gendro who says or gendro who
says uh hello Dr Tyson Dr dettinger and
Chuck
noology I don't know what that is but he
says what is it chemically or
biologically that makes rare prod
mushrooms so delicious and why are they
so damned rare can't we just grow them
like potatoes we have mushrooms and
we've got the dirt what's the big hold
up look at that so I guess I guess uh
he's referring to Truffles truffles yes
truffles yeah so truffles are um just a
strategy that many mushrooms and non-m
mushrooms have taken to get their spores
dispersed by animals so this is evolved
many times hundreds of times actually
but the one the trou that we typically
eat as humans they they're in the genus
tuber which is a reference to the potato
as it turns out and they have to be
collected in the wild or sometimes grown
in Orchards but it can take years for
those to mature and be harvestable and
the reason is complex so one is that
they rely on the living roots of trees
to grow and we haven't yet been able to
figure out how to mimic a live Tree in a
lab so so they're basically parasitic to
the
tree you could look at it that way but
most people have viewed it as a
mutualism so they benefit the tree by
giving the tree nutrients and water from
the soil and in exchange the tree feeds
the fungus for sugar that it makes
through photosynthesis wow and this is
persisted this allowed land to be
colonized by plants three uh 450 million
years ago and has persisted to this day
in 90% of all land plants look at that
so it's kind of an amazing partnership
between plants and fungi that has
transformed the Earth's landscape and
make made it hospitable to animals like
us wow so we we kind of owe our
existence to to to mushrooms wow that's
a that is a just terribly fascinating
little factoid it's awesome all right uh
this is Abram pada and Abram says hello
Dr Tyson Dr detener Lord nice as we live
in an exciting era of rapidly growing
space industry can you speak to the role
of fungi in something like a Mars
settlement which aims to be self-
sustaining could it play some part in
making soil from regali if so what else
would it need to accomplish that also
assuming that there are sometime uh
assuming that at some time some amount
of soil is present on Mars do you expect
it will be a vital food source for the
settlers so and are we taking are we
taking mushrooms to space do they make a
good space food that
is uh I think we will have to do that
yes um oh so yeah they're really good at
decomposing things so if you think of
your compost bin if you have that one of
those in your yard um That's essential
for breaking down dead organic material
and turning it into new forms of
nutrients to grow plants so if you
imagine first trying to establish a
colony in Mars you're not going to be
ordering up fertilizer off Amazon right
you're going to have to make your own
while you're there Amazon delivers to
Mars it it just keeps scrolling down you
see oh okay I missed that so okay so so
maybe fungi are obsolete colonizing
colonizing Mars I don't know but I also
think referring to our earlier question
about um their nutritive properties this
would be a good source of protein for
early colonizers uh when there aren't
large herds of cattle yet roing Mars
cool I think I think they're essential
and one other fun fact about fungi a lot
of fungi can are resistant to high
levels of radiation uh and in fact some
fungi can actually convert radiation
energy into their own metabolism so
there's good reason why fungi are going
to be probably a critical component of a
of establishing a settlement on Mars cre
that's so cool so now wait a minute you
say they're highly resistant to
radiation um some is that is that
because they're 90% water or is it
because they have some properties that
are resist you know just you know
whatever properties that might be and
then could we be able to take that and
make a skin for a
spaceship as a shield
yeah I like where you're going with that
I I'm not the one to help out with that
but um somebody should definitely look
into that I don't know exactly why they
are some fungi are highly resistant to
radiation I there's probably some
biochemical basis to it um but I'm not
familiar that familiar with it he
interesting interesting well part of it
could be just complexity I mean
mushrooms are pretty simple aren't
they well simple in in what in what
sense because structurally simple I mean
a lot of complex things going on then
any kind of pulsive radiation can do SAR
damage to what you are if you're simple
I think you're right um the the life
form the sort of vegetative phase is
very simple hasn't changed in 400 and
some odd million years maybe even longer
um because it's a very successful
strategy but when you get to the
reproductive phases those get to be
quite complex there's some very
sophisticated uh mechanisms that would
easily be disrupted through mutation so
I would say they're they're complex at a
different scale but yeah you're right
generally speaking the kind of the
growth habit is pretty simple right okay
all right this is Paul patula and Paul
patsa from Slovakia says hello Dr Tyson
Dr dettinger Lord nice I would like to
know how do the interactions between
funi and the human
microbiome influence health and disease
what are the possible beneficial roles
of fungi and human health so is there
are there any medicinal applications we
know about silos cybin but that's more
you know mental are there any medicinal
uh applications for fungi there there
are some uh there's a long history of
use of some mushrooms in traditional
Chinese medicine primarily um the jury's
out I would say on just how you know
useful they are in in modern medicine um
but potentially there's there's
something there uh in it reference to
the microbiome however we do have fungi
that live inside of us that are pensal
that is they live there they don't seem
to have an impact on us but probably
they're doing something for us and we
just haven't yet understood it fully but
we have yeasts that live in our guts um
these can get out of control sometimes
and cause s um cause conditions like
Auto Brewery syndrome where you have
yeast that sounds
delightful Auto
Brewery yeah so you're walking around
drunk all the time because the yeasts
are fermenting the food you're eating
and turning it into alcohol and then
you're drunk and this is a pretty rare
thing but it's happens multiple times
that is
amazing dude you want to go get a drink
dude I am drunk all the
time you keep your drinks sir I am
always
drunk wow I mean it's much it's much
cheaper yes that's for sure but uh
there's there's emerging I'll just say
this very quickly there's emerging
evidence that fungal infections have a
wide range of impacts on human health
from Alzheimer's disease to cancer and
there's one fungus that's been
implicated in um causing the
accelerated uh growth of pancreatic
cancer and there's a mechanism um that's
been established for this so it's not
fungus you've eaten it's a fungus that's
just somehow thriving inside of you it's
a fungus that grows commensally on our
skin it's actually the cause of dandruff
it's called malesia and sometimes people
can get systemic infections of it and
when it gets into the pancreas either
causing or during cancerous growth of
the pancreas it can that's what rapidly
seems to rapidly cause rapid growth of
the cancerous cells in the pancreas wow
jeez that's crazy I know yeah so we're
just starting to understand the impact
of fungi on on human health so again if
this had been a branch of the academy at
the turn of the century for example we
would have been far more along than we
are right now in the academic
understanding of its uses and
pitfalls perhaps but you know these
organisms are super hard to study
they're they're mostly microscopic
they're hard to get into culture and to
to look at and manipulate and it's
really only with recent advances in
technology that we've had the tools to
really interrogate in a real way some of
these associations like with the human
microbiome so I'm not sure we really
would be that much further ahead had um
yeah had there been more mycologists
than ornithologists but we'll never know
well plus there's the tandem advance of
other technologies that gives you the
power to do the analysis that would not
have existed decades ago exactly right
right okay Chuck time for like a couple
more like half questions all right
actually this is uh Boer Deeter and just
dovetailing on what you just said um he
says hi I'm from Belgian humans have
consumed psychedelic substances for
thousands of years and many known cases
of animals getting drunk at high do you
think that making mind-altering
substances illegal has stunted our
growth and our wisdom I'm worried about
this we're not allowed to get high but
we're allowed to consume ungodly amounts
of advertisements every day I'm worried
that we'll stop thinking and stop being
creative or revolutionary if we stay
sober for long periods of time do you
have any thoughts on this please this is
a guy who really wants to get
high well maybe maybe he should relocate
to Amsterdam it's not that far away
that's true now now now is um are are
mushrooms ell or hallucinogenics are
they uh uh legal in in in in the
Netherlands so mushrooms have beenal
marijuana and hashes yeah yeah yeah and
mushrooms were for a while and now
they're no longer legal but there's some
loopholes people have have found that
they can still sell hallucinogenic
mushroom products that aren't mushrooms
so it is still possible to get them
there um yeah how do I answer that
question though I I mean
I you know I'm a myologist so what do I
know but I do think that Altered States
Of Consciousness how in whatever form
they they take whatever the cause of
them is is important for humans to
understand better their place in the
world and and to come up with new ideas
that can result in Innovation and there
have been some very high-profile cases
of people that have attributed their
mushroom trips or LSD trips
to their success like Steve Jobs for
example so you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't say that it's necessary for
every individual per se but I do think
it's a tool in our toolkit that we
shouldn't just um disregard out of
hand cool I'm for it so it's a access
point an entry an entry yes it's it's
one one tool one access point yeah all
right cool one more Chuck this is Teresa
anasi and she says hi folks I'm allergic
to mushrooms this seems to be an unusual
allergy what could it be about mushrooms
that make me allergic it's Teresa from
Long Beach Mississippi El wants to get
high and can't
okay yeah well I don't I don't know what
the cause of it would be and I don't
know if it's all mushrooms or just a
mushroom um but they twoo you know
they're they're comp they're comp Le Lex
organisms um cellularly biochemically uh
fudi are you know biochemical Wizards as
one of my colleagues has put it um
because they they compete in an
environment where um their only
interaction is through chemicals that's
how they communicate and so they make a
lot of chemicals and so there's a good
chance that there's a chemical in there
that somebody's going to react to but um
could very well just be proteins or or
even the components of the cell walls
which are indigestible to us they're
they have cell walls made out of kiten
which is the same structure found in
insect uh exoskeletons and crab shells
um and then they have something that's
very much like cellulose in plants which
is what we call fiber um so you know it
could be just that as well okay I
actually have one last question from
Kevin theer who is a friend of the show
and Kevin says are there any new species
of mushrooms popping up and if there are
popping up I see what he did there did
you see that yeah uh and if there are is
there a Telltale sign of which ones that
send you on a trip or kill you yes
there's a label on the side oh yeah he
said or is it all trial and error also
in the spirit of mushrooms Pino Noir is
a classic pairing for any mushroom dish
rotto being my favorite I would select
anything produced by Lou Lor from
burgundy
oh see we get free wine advice
that's why I read it
yeah but but let me broaden the question
there there's there's I think at our
museum at the American Museum of Natural
History there's a group there are people
who have gone through Central Park right
there in the middle of Manhattan and
have identified species of plants
previously un
unidentified all right which is what
when you get a new species that's of
course what that means and I haven't
read up close on that whether they these
have evolved since we've had Manhattan
or WEA just no one looked hard enough so
there seems to be so many species of
fungus you must be discovering them
every
day practically yes um but it's it's so
overwhelming we just don't have the time
because that's not necessarily valued
just describing new diversity uh today
we don't necessarily have the time to
focus on that he's not into diversity
you heard that I heard it yeah there's
there's a big there's a big attack on
Dei right now big attack on here's an
example of it mushroom is trying to have
identity exactly trying to get Equity
it's trying to get inclusion yeah and
you say oh it's not worth it yeah okay
you do know I live in the state of
[Music]
[Laughter]
Utah oh that was great
okay so I let me let me help you bail
out of this I think what you're saying
is
that the behavior of mushrooms is more
interesting and important than simply
identifying every single one that's out
there right right and and so you know
I'll throw some numbers out at you 95%
of fungal diversity has never been
documented wow 95% so we've we've
described about 150,000 species of fungi
but the estimates range from 2.2 to 12
million species that are out there of
just f just fungus of all kinds and
mushrooms represent a small portion but
a fairly diverse um group most visible
fungus the most visible yeah they're the
most charismatic right if I'm allowed to
yes exact hello I'm a
mushroom how's it
going do you come to this tree root
often
H nice to see you pick up lines in the
melium I've been told I'm very
charismatic got a lot of Riz uh so the
question was are are you identifying new
species ohus so the answer is just Plum
yes basically yeah yeah we encounter
them all the time I would say every time
I go out I I can't identify something
that I've picked up wow regardless of
where I am whether it's a Well
documented place like parts of North
America or Europe or somewhere where
nobody's ever collected a fungus before
um in in many cases there's something
something there that I don't recognize
now that doesn't always translate into a
new species but um often it does
especially when you're outside of the
well documented areas if you're going to
decide whether it's tasty healthy will
get send you on a brain trip or kill you
do you give it to mice
first we should um so we use
philogenetic uh prediction to inform
whether or not to try a new mushroom to
eat and I am not somebody that's very
I'm pretty risk averse when it comes to
eating mushrooms just because I don't
like things that taste bad I'm not
worried about getting poisoned but I
have a a delicate palette so I'm pretty
you know I I use that um rationale to
say if I'm in the jungle of Africa and I
see something that looks like a European
Chantell I'm going to give it a try
because I know all chantells are edible
at least all the ones that we know about
so far and they're usually delicious
whereas if I'm in the forest in Cameroon
and I see a brown mushroom that stains
blue when I scratch it that's a Hallmark
of mushrooms that have syosin but is not
unique to them and so I wouldn't take
the risk even if I really wanted to get
high in the jungle because there's a
reasonable chance that that blue
discoloration is a convergent trait
something that evolved
independently and so I could get very
sick from that oh okay okay all right
well we're GNA call next time we go
mushroom hunting we're calling you yes
exactly do next time I'm out with my
pig you can't use pigs because the pigs
will dig the Truffle up and eat it
before you can get it right well the
idea dog yeah the dog is the way to go
that's yeah that I saw a great little
documentary about uh I believe believe
there in Italy uh where there's a u um
community of elderly Italian men and
their dogs and all they do uh is hunt
truffles that's all they do is hunt
Truffles and uh it's it's very it's a
very you know touching little
documentary you know yes more because
but more because of the relationship
between the men and their dogs right
right seems like a very peaceful life
yeah yeah so uh have you seen end on
this then have you seen the the the last
of us or what's the name of that show
The Last of Us have you can can you
comment on its authenticity sorry
comment on its
plausibility now it's authenticity is uh
is it a clever use of fungus in
storytelling versus bad use of
fungus I mean I think it's clever uh but
it's not plausible given our current
understanding of those types of fungi
and the hosts that they parasitize
that's why it's called science fiction
so given what they've show have they
been did they have one of you one a m a
mopic person on on staff not that I'm
aware of but they can call me up
anytime well there you go The Gauntlet
is thrown down no because the better
it's Sci-Fi movies they have someone on
staff where at least you begin in an
authentic Place yeah and then your
creativity takes the story tell telling
beyond that and uh that's that reminds
me of the Mark Twain quote first get
your facts straight then distort them at
your leisure and it always makes for a
stronger story especially in a world
where you have scientifically literate
comic coners who are going to talk about
your movie if you don't get it right you
know they'll tell you what's what's
going down right so well yeah I mean HBO
can offer me up a bottle of lure Pon
Noir and I'll be there in a minute
you'll be there Truffle in hand
okay there'll be Lou Lor yes in burgundy
there's a sha tour in Bordeaux uh right
to I don't know if they related but it's
been great to have you here just to even
know that I'm glad somebody's on top of
the situation and the the what is the
title of your this submission to the
National Academy of Sciences which it's
already published what's What's the
title of it yeah it's phog genomics of
silos and evolution of the syosin
biosynthetic gene cluster yeah so you
you went for the short title huh that's
right
so no so this is so this is an important
place for people to turn if they want to
know what Sila cybin is doing or what
it's about or what its future might hold
right I mean this is reviews this is a
review paper which is what the National
Academy of Sciences is good at which is
the the the the summation of years
sometimes Decades of research of many to
come up with some understanding of it
and just for those who don't remember or
never knew the National Academy of
Sciences was um founded by Abraham
Lincoln in 1863 when he clearly had
other things he needed to think about uh
he wanted an arm of science to exist
independent of government but uh
responsive to government when the
government had questions and needs and
need and had to advice so um public the
the publication series I say is one of
the most important uh uh shelves of
science you could ever assemble uh the
review papers of the National Academy of
Sciences so that's my shout out for
objective truths rather than your
favorite person on YouTube who tells you
whether or not you should get vaccinated
you know right as as they're teaching
you how to make sour
dough
all right chuck if you experiment with
more mushrooms give us a call we'll
we'll invite bin back and we'll get a
full analysis oh yeah well now I have
homework that's
great fantastic I I love it I'm up to
the
challenge all right this is been Star
Talk Cosmic queries the the everything
you needed to know about psilocybin and
more I'm Neil degrass Tyson you're
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking
up
[Music]
a